Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
Are you else?
I'm a cybernetic organism,
so
it is brought to you by a new sponsor,
so listen up folks.
This is a good one because have you ever wanted to be as powerful as a bullet
wearing Ninja from 1980s movie or as flamboyant as big gay Al Big Al in south
park or as sleek as a black panther in the Amazon on the hunt wealth?
There's great news because I've been testing this product that you wrap around
your genitals and it makes you feel like a superhero and it is called me undies.
I've spent the last two to three weeks traveling with underwear from these guys
and they are comfy.
I got to tell you,
it feels like a Geisha has giving your groin a hug and it's not just for dudes,
but if you go to [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
that's m,
e e u n d,
I e s.com forward slash Tim,
you can see all of the underwear that I've been wearing.
There's some pretty ridiculous ones.
And I will also highlight my favorite,
you'll probably be able to guess which it is.
These underwear made from micro model,
which is extruded from Austrian beechwood trees in the Alps.
Yes.
Fancy.
And it's two times softer than cotton,
scientifically tested using the [inaudible] method developed in Kyoto.
You know those Japanese very crafty and uh,
I will say a few things.
Number one,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
you get to see all of these spectacular underwear that I've been wearing and I
am a bit of an underwear connoisseur,
socks,
fashion sense with sweat pants,
not so much underwear.
I understand.
So check them out and if you go to [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
you will also be able to see lots of hot ladies wearing me undies,
female underwear.
And that's just a lot of goodness for both the men and the women out there.
So check it out.
Me undies.com forward slash Tim,
I love these underwear and a,
I'm going to be packing tonight probably six to 12 pair to take with me to
Australia.
They're great.
Check em out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Okay,
why hello thrillers,
killers and a hundred dollar billers.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I've had a lot of whey protein,
I've had a lot of supplementation,
PCA's,
few other goodies like synthetic ketones and I am raring and roaring to go with
this episode.
So I don't want to give you too long of a prelude,
but if you haven't joined me before on the Tim Ferriss show,
this entire program is about deconstructing excellence.
It is about interviewing world class performers the best at what they do to
identify the rituals,
routines,
influences,
books,
tips and tools and so on that you can use.
So borrowing best practices from the best in the world.
And this episode we have a very fun guest.
He is widely requested and now he's here.
Chris Sacca or Chris Saka,
depending on how you say his name,
he was recently on the cover of Forbes magazine.
They're mitis issue and the title says Venture Cowboy,
the 39 year old behind Uber,
Twitter and Instagram might be the best angel ever.
So why all the bad blood and burned bridges.
And then the article,
if you look inside is titled how Super Angel Chris Saka made billions burned
bridges and crafted the best seed portfolio ever.
I've known Chris for quite some time and I've mentioned before that in the game
of early stage investing,
I've learned a ton from a lot of people,
but three people stand out immediately.
Mike Maples Jr and then Chris Saka and novel Ramakant.
Those are three who've been very,
very generous with their time.
And this episode is wide ranging.
It's not just about investing,
it is about life design.
It is about career decisions and much,
much more.
So please enjoy my conversation with Chris Sacca.
Chris,
my fans have demanded it.
People have asked foreign wife,
you'd be on the show.
So thanks for
cutting out some time in this spectacular trip.
Be psyched.
You're here.
We're,
uh,
we're on Necker island in the British Virgin Islands.
And my first time to the Bvi,
it is paradise.
Not Too surprisingly.
And for people who don't have much context on you and number one,
is it Sacca or Soka?
That's totally regional.
I'm from,
I'm from near Buffalo,
New York,
so it's Sanka it's very nasally.
You gotta get it right.
And then to see it again.
I'm Chris Sacca.
Hey,
you guys use guys.
So do you introduce yourself a second?
Let's see.
What's your name?
Chris.
You know,
I'm more of focused on spelling it cause I was like,
what the hell?
Something,
I guess a CCA,
but I guess it's Saca.
Chris Sacca Sakhile comes off my sack.
Yeah.
All right,
cool.
And you grew up,
like you said,
on the east coast.
Uh,
but let's,
let's do a quick,
not entire retrospective,
but to give people the present tense.
What are you best known for Cyber Professionally
or personally?
Uh,
both.
The secretary that would amazing wife,
all three.
So professionally I'm known for being a venture capitalists and Angel Investors
and venture capitalists.
And I was one of the first investors in Twitter,
one of the first investors in Uber,
Instagram,
Kickstarter,
docker optimized Lee.
Um,
look out Twilio,
it's going down my unicorns.
So you have,
you have this,
this,
uh,
sort of Unicorn radar and the,
you,
you of course had the angel investing experience and then you had your fund
experience.
Could you tell people a little bit about how that has gone for you
in terms of,
in terms of managing my funds,
your first,
you're just here for your first fund.
I would assume that is one of the reasons why you were just recently on the
cover of Forbes magazine.
Horrifyingly.
Uh,
God,
he tell t shirt,
we can talk about the shirt.
Uh,
no.
So our first fund is turning out to,
it looks like it might be the most successful fund in the history of venture
capital.
Um,
we had Twitter in there.
We had to burn their Instagrams and their dockers still in their optimized is
still in there.
We had some very cool stuff like Zen coder was in there.
Um,
so we've had some good deals that have gotten bought along the way,
but it's,
um,
it's,
uh,
it's just taken off like there's no,
like no fund has ever done.
And you know,
right now it's,
I don't think Uber has done growing.
All right.
And so,
uh,
certainly hopes that,
yeah,
so we're at,
we're at somewhere around 250 x multiple on the fun.
That's amazing.
And I want to,
I'll start off,
some people have followed our friendship over the years.
The heckling on the endless heckling on Twitter
and a
like,
I,
I mean,
no,
it's,
I'm very sincere and authentic when I ask,
when do you and,
and Kevin Rose are gonna release the podcast episode where you guys make out.
And Kevin told me that was behind the pay wall.
It's the bonus wrestling behind
the paywall.
And I think we have to wait until there's a slump in our careers and then you
have that in your back pocket,
pull a car dash and reinvent ourselves.
Uh,
but the,
the gratitude I want to express first before we get into things,
uh,
is multifold.
So some people have read the four hour body.
Might recall that I mentioned you in that book for introducing me to total
immersion,
which was I think the first time we ever met you brought it up.
This is that the,
was that the barbecue that had Kira is actually through outside his apartment.
And uh,
you said something along the lines of when I described how,
how bad I was at swimming and pretty much incapable of swimming.
You said I have the answer to your prayers.
It was a great response,
which ended up being accurate in this case and was total immersion swimming.
So I learned to swim for the first time properly in my thirties using that
method.
So thank you for that.
And also since the early days have been a very open book when it came to talking
to you about investing and advising,
uh,
and of course the,
the legal notepad has been now transcribed into Evernote.
So I have many soccer files that are all very favorable.
But how did you,
uh,
what were some of your formative experiences growing up?
Uh,
well let me,
let me just talk to what you were just saying in terms of being
generous with the,
I mean,
first of all,
the total immersion thing is like a religion.
When you get it,
you get it right.
And I went from dragging my ass around the pool,
just kicking too hard and paddling too hard too.
When total immersion at me,
I could suddenly swim a couple of miles and get bored.
And so I was just there as an apostle man when you were like,
I'm struggling with swimming.
And that was,
I was just geeking out in the same way you can get going on lifting techniques
and stuff like that.
I'm like,
you're in my world now.
I'm going to,
I'm going to talk about swimming.
But at the same of the investing stuff,
I mean,
I was really lucky when it came time for me to get started as an investor.
I had many,
many guys.
They're paying it forward and teaching me about the game.
Guys like Josh Koppelman at first round,
Tony Conrad at true ventures,
uh,
really being generous with their time and helping me figure out what was going
on.
The guys at industry ventures were indispensable for me,
Hans Weldon's and his team.
And so,
um,
and so for me,
when you came along and started asking questions about that,
not only I feel like I was paying it forward again,
but in the same way you and I never invest in a simple idea.
The execution is everything.
I don't feel like I'm really giving any secrets away by telling you what the
approach is.
You still have to go execute on it,
right?
So I can give you my lens on how I think about this stuff and you know,
things other people have taught me things I think I might've improved upon,
et cetera.
But I can,
I can lay that playbook on you.
And if you're not good at this,
you can't fake it.
And so I don't have any fear and kind of disclosing my secrets to B teamers,
uh,
because they're not going to end up competing with me and your case.
You're good at it.
And so it's become an incredible side business for you in addition to everything
you do,
you know,
with media.
Um,
but I,
but there's no fear and in putting that stuff out there.
And the other lesson they taught me is that if I get to you and teach you some
of this stuff,
you're going to naturally be an ally of mine in this industry.
So if I can get in there and kind of teach you how do I think about the world,
how can I be helpful to companies and you start using that same method,
then we're gonna end up doing deals together and you and I have and we've made a
fair amount of money doing that.
And so,
um,
so I didn't,
I didn't want to leave that on answered.
Sure.
Well,
I,
uh,
it's,
it's really been fun to watch you sort of evolve and grow and experiment also in
investing in just coming back.
You know,
we can,
we can rewind the clock back to your upbringing a little bit later on,
but just since we're on the topic,
what were,
what were some of the pieces of advice that you were given by say the guys that
you mentioned or other people early on that helped you to approach early stage
investing in a more intelligent way?
Yeah,
I mean,
a couple of guys have said things that I've now taken an animal gam and of
codified.
So I have rules for investing now that were definitely influenced by a lot of
these guys give me advice and things that I've now put to work.
So one is only get involved in deals,
Ryan.
No,
I can personally impact the outcome.
Now there's no guarantee that I can take it from,
you know,
x to sold or x to IPO.
But I need to know that I can have a material impact to make something that's,
um,
to make something more likely to succeed.
So the second reel I've developed,
and this again influenced by guys along the way,
who've given me advice is start with something that's already great that you can
make more awesome.
You know?
But don't start with something shitty that you think you can make good.
And that's hard.
Like when you work in a company and a lot of your listeners,
I don't work in big companies,
you have to work on the shit that somebody hands you,
right?
So you're just dealt a really your delta two seven and you're like,
well,
okay,
that's what the boss gave me.
I got to play this handout.
When you get into investing,
your default stance should be no cause most deals suck.
Most deals won't make money.
Most companies will fail.
And the temptation always is you see your first deal and you're like,
okay,
I can,
no,
I can be helpful to these guys.
I knew I could make this shitty thing better.
And so your first few deals are always the worst.
It's how I lost 50 grand on my first deal.
And I was just like,
oh,
it's like for 25% of what I had hypothetically allocated to two years.
I was just like,
oh my God.
That's because you get in that room and you're like,
okay,
I know how I can make this thing better.
Right?
And you forget that you need to start from something that's already
independently pretty damn good and then make it better.
So,
um,
our third principle is,
uh,
is give yourself a chance to get rich.
And that was something that was influenced more by a,
he's fund investors are like,
Hey,
it's all well and good to throw 25 k around into some of these deals,
but most of them won't be home runs.
Most of them won't turn into UNICORNS.
Uh,
most of them are going to require a ton of work.
a bunch of those will fail,
but a bunch of them will be successful.
The tune of,
of doubling that money.
But over years and years of work.
And so I've sold companies,
I sold a company in to Amazon where I saw three x on a $50,000 investment in a
fund.
By the time my phone got paid back and I got my part back and I was,
had been busting my ass and that company for a couple of years,
like I barely had money left to buy the guys dinner to celebrate the deal.
And so,
um,
so that's another thing is leaving ourselves enough room to benefit from scale
going in at prices that are low enough that if the company's as successful as we
think it's going to be,
we've given ourselves a chance to get rich.
And then the fourth thing that I think we evolved,
um,
internally or that I involved was just be proud of every deal.
There's stuff that I've passed on that I just don't regret it at all.
It seemed like maybe a good way to make money,
but I don't wanna have to explain to my kids that's how I made money.
And so,
um,
so those are kind of the guiding principle that I think have been shaped,
but categorically what would some of those be?
Uh,
I'll,
you know,
mistype domains,
right?
So that's a great way to make money.
People are stupid and they mistype type stuff all the time.
And you can put ads on sites that don't really look like ads.
Uh,
subscription businesses that make it impossible for you to get your,
to cancel your subscription.
Ever forced.
Yeah,
you can sign out annuity.
you can sign up online,
but you need to send them a postcard,
you know,
to,
to cancel like that kind of stuff.
I see that stuff.
Right.
Um,
you know,
people making up statutes,
unsubstantiated claims about the effectiveness of their stuff.
Um,
you know,
this,
this anonymous content stuff that we just,
it was just going and bad places.
So I just want to be really proud of our deals.
And so those I think are some principles that have been shaped by a lot of these
guys.
Give me advice along the way.
What are,
when you meet with founders for the first time,
what are,
is there anything that disqualifies them quickly?
Are there certain sort of red flags that you look for?
Yeah,
so this,
this is evolved over time.
You know,
I've now been doing this for awhile and if done over a hundred deals and have
seen a bunch of those workout and I've seen a bunch of not work out and I read
all the posts that my peers in the industry,
right,
other vcs,
everyone's constantly stabbing at,
Hey,
what is the rule?
Like how do you,
how do you get into one of these meetings?
Um,
so let me first,
I have a couple of parameters.
One is I almost only invest in things that are already live in production.
Uh,
just know hypothetical's no ideas.
I think there might be one exception to that and it was a particularly gifted
entrepreneur that I already worked with before.
But other than that,
we look for stuff that is,
um,
that is already actually being,
you know,
that has users that has,
uh,
that that can demonstrate that the team is capable of building and launching
stuff together and getting it out there in the market.
Um,
but that said,
then the one thing that will turn me off right now is if I see that in the pitch
the founder is trying to convince themself if,
if I can pick up on any hint that,
that they don't in their like in their marrow believe in this story,
then it's no dice is,
I look at all the most successful founders I've backed,
the thing they have is inevitability of success.
There are no conditional statements coming out of their mouths.
There's no like,
well,
if it works it would be rad.
Instead,
it's just always,
and you talked to Kevin System and Instagram when he was working on it himself,
he was literally a sole guy working on the product and he's like,
so when we get to 50 million users will roll out this other stuff and you're
just like,
wait,
what?
He's just peering into the future,
kind of looking through you into something in the future and you're just like,
I got to get along for the ride with this guy.
Um,
the same thing when you talk to Evan Williams when it comes to talking about the
likelihood of success of his products,
he just knows like,
he just knew Twitter would be a big thing.
He knows medium will be a big thing.
He doesn't need to convince you of that right now.
He just knows.
You talked to Patrick and John Collison at stripe and of course they're building
for this thing to be a big dominant company and it just will be.
You spent time with Travis,
you're,
you're an investor in Uber.
Was there any doubt at any time that Uber would dominate the planet?
There's just,
there's no doubt.
Can you,
can you just share an,
there's an anecdote I've,
I've,
I think we probably talked about over drinks at some point,
but the uh,
uh,
we tennis,
we tennis.
Could you have a skewed view?
Tennis?
Yeah.
Could you play the,
to tell the story?
Two years ago,
we're up at my house and you know,
we,
we live up in the mountains and Truckee and uh,
it was over the holidays,
so my parents were there,
I think it was actually new year's Day.
So Travis and I had been,
we have a tradition up there on New Year's Eve.
We go snow shoeing at midnight and drink champagne out in the meadow and stuff.
So I think we are pretty,
um,
it's pretty rough morning.
But Travis sitting on the couch and my dad since have some weakness and he
challenged them to a game of we tennis,
so on the Nintendo Wi my dad's not a bad player.
He's pretty good.
So they,
uh,
Travis like,
okay,
Mr. Sack usher and he picks up the controller and they play the first couple of
games and they're tight games with Travis winsome.
And my dad is,
they're taking like full swings with the paddle,
you know,
and it's like breaking a little sweat and Travis is still blurry from the night
before,
barely breaking his wrist and he's beating my dad.
My Dad's like,
what the hell is this?
And then there was that a Negro Montoya moment,
Princess Bride Stories.
Look,
Travis turns my dad and says,
I'm sorry but I'm not left handed.
Or you know,
I forget if it's left or right,
but he switches hands with the controller and the next three games.
My Dad never touches the ball.
There were no points score on any of Travis is serves.
It has like what the hell is going on?
Like what is this?
And after the torture gotten to be too much,
Travis just says,
well let me take you to the global leader board.
I'm sorry I got,
you know,
I'm a sack.
I,
I didn't mean to be holding out.
And he goes to the global leaderboard and Travis Kalanick was ranked number two
in the world that we tennis in spirits I have now.
Uber was already a thing then like literally he was already building a startup,
but he's just so obsessive,
so competitive.
And that's the thing is we look across the portfolio at all of the most kick ass
companies.
That's something they just have,
you know,
right up front is,
is that they're not hoping and praying for success.
They know what's going to happen.
Now on that note though,
to pull,
pull out two,
two names,
for instance,
you have an Evan Williams,
blogger,
Twitter medium,
etc. Then you have Travis,
uh,
personality wise,
at least from the outside looking in very different personality types.
And I bumped into some investors to say,
well,
I only invest in merciless a sort of off highly offensive offensive meaning not
defensive,
um,
CEOs than other people were like,
no,
I only invest in people who,
like,
I would watch my kids or whatever it might be.
But what are the commonalities or are there commonalities when you look across
these founders for whom success and massive scale just seems predestined?
What are the commonalities?
Well,
I think something,
so we'll,
we'll take avid Travis examples,
but,
uh,
but across our most successful founders,
um,
you know,
Susan,
Matt,
Matt Mullenweg,
yeah,
that's a,
that's $1 billion company now billion plus.
Um,
these guys were all incredible,
incredible listeners.
So when they do open their mouths,
they can be bombastic and offensive and aggressive and in your face.
But they're all incredible listeners.
And I don't just mean in casual conversation.
I mean these guys go out of their way to interview other people and they really,
uh,
if you catch AV,
he's got a notebook always.
And if you ask them to see if your,
you know,
the last few pages of the notebook,
he's just meeting with other people whose,
uh,
you know,
billionaires and,
and,
and kind of leaders whose jobs might not overlap with his at all,
but from whom he's learning voracious reader.
Part of why medium started was he was really back deep in a long form content
when he took a break from Twitter.
And so that guy is just constantly learning,
studying,
studying.
And so when he speaks,
it matters.
But he's listening more than he speaks.
You know that about Moen Wag,
one of the most thoughtful people.
I've never seen anyone read as many books as that guy does and retain all the
knowledge.
And you also,
it's a bee and he listens to anyone that he's sitting down with.
It doesn't matter if it's,
you know,
the,
the waitress or a primary school teacher.
We've done a lot of traveling together.
He was on the podcast also a very good listener.
All right.
Yeah.
And so,
and again,
you just look across the board.
These guys are learning,
they're modeling,
they're constantly researching,
they're gathering data.
You know,
Travis would think at a competitive disadvantage for you to know exactly what's
going on in his head sometimes.
So he'll listen.
And,
uh,
and it's an amazing talent.
I think dry is a commonality across those people
with the,
uh,
the investing game that you've obviously been a participant in it for quite
awhile now.
Um,
you have to say no a lot.
And,
uh,
I was,
you know,
took a close look at,
at poker in the last with the TV show.
And there were a couple of quotes that that came up quite a bit along the lines
of,
you know,
I made my money sitting,
not playing hands and,
but,
but that having been said,
what are some of the deals,
the whales that got away?
Yeah.
So first of all,
I mean,
this is a rigged game,
right?
And,
and I'm just looking to make it even more rigged.
So for those who don't know,
venture capital,
I mean it's totally unfair.
People gave me their money,
I draw a management fee off it,
so they'd pay me to take their money and invest it for them if I make money,
then I paid him back the management fee.
And then after that we split the profits and I got a really big chunk of the
profits.
Uh,
and if I lose money,
that's fine.
Uh,
I don't know.
It doesn't come out of my pocket.
I keep my fee and my investors lose money.
That's how this industry works.
That's bananas.
Right?
And at some point it's going to break because it,
it's,
um,
you've also incepted me with the term bananas,
which I've started using compulsively.
It Mazzeo also has done the same thing who works with Chris.
Yeah.
It's,
it's just an unforgivably unfair,
a rigged game that's in favor of the venture capitalists.
And so,
um,
so the,
the reality is the risk of an investor doesn't begin to compare to the risk of a
founder.
And so,
you know,
that's one thing that kind of drives me crazy sometimes about some investors.
And I love the entrepreneurial spirit that goes into building a firm.
I mean,
I built my firm from scratch and there's certainly founder type lessons in
there,
but,
um,
but you're cash flow positive from day one when you start a venture fund,
uh,
and your,
your downside is incredibly limited by the structure of the fun.
So,
so that said,
what it allows me to do is place some bets on some stuff that I,
I'd like to think success is inevitable,
those things.
But I can take,
I can look at the risk analysis and say,
okay,
is a binary outcome a one or a zero?
And some of those things just don't get there.
You know,
one of my,
uh,
one of my kind of constant recurring nightmares about this stuff I passed on.
That's exactly,
that's what I was,
that's what I was trying to ask.
You know,
I've done some deals where I thought it was gonna be a lot bigger and you know,
and ends up going away.
But,
so the Dropbox guys,
I met those guys very early on while they're still in y Combinator.
I got an early look,
you know,
had an opportunity to do the deal and I pulled this guys a set and I was like,
hey,
look at Google.
We were using a version of this called a platypus,
which became g drive and they're going to crush you guys,
man.
So you should probably find some other product to pivot to.
I probably caused me a hundreds of millions of dollars.
Um,
the,
uh,
they give you a pat on the head and won't go away.
No,
I mean it's,
when I see drew the CEO of Dropbox,
I bring it up before he can.
This is good.
I just get,
I get it out there right away.
Um,
the airbnb guys at,
why comment or same thing,
correct.
Business and I did an amazing business and wanting to be proud of too.
I mean,
that's,
I'm,
I'm really jealous.
I'm not in that business,
not just for the money,
but I love what they do.
I'm really,
um,
admire them a lot in their culture,
but at the time they were,
they were allowing you to rent out a room in somebody's house while the owner
was still there.
And that just seemed really scary to me.
And I pull the guys aside and I was just like,
guys,
you know,
somebody who's going to get raped or murdered in one of these houses and the
blood is going to be on your hands.
I literally said that out loud to them.
What's that worth?
Like 15 or 20 billion now?
Now in fairness,
you,
you're probably not wrong,
right?
I mean,
at a certain scale,
that scale,
it has to happen.
It's going to have,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
I like to say sometimes like when you think about scale,
like someone who works at Walmart murdered someone last night,
right?
There's just no doubt about it at that scale.
Well,
the few million employees,
one of the murdered somebody last night,
you've to look at it like,
uh,
Edward Norton in fight club,
like an actuarial analysis for insurance,
which is terrifying,
but that's the reality of big numbers.
Um,
but I'll tell you,
so there's one other famous one.
There's a bunch of these,
but um,
actually I'll give you too nick because I wasn't reminded us until recently.
Nick Woodman from Gopro came to Google.
Now I wasn't an investor at the time,
but I did a lot of Google's investments and partnerships.
And so Eric Schmidt,
CEO of Google said,
Hey,
will you come in here and sit with this pitch?
You know,
he's a friend of a friend said,
we've got to meet this guy.
So woman comes in with Gopro and Eric's like,
I dunno.
And I was like,
we'd be,
we'd be foolish to do this deal.
How is this guy from Santa Cruz going to compete with all these Asians and
building hardware?
You know,
you can't,
you can't hold a candle like the Taiwanese and the Koreans.
It was like,
no dice man,
let this guy go.
And I think I introduced him to somebody over Youtube,
just as a constellation.
I saw that dude this winter skiing,
he's worth like three or $4 billion now.
And he didn't forget that meeting.
So,
and then the snapchat guys,
I gave a talk in La and they came up to me,
I never met them before.
They came up after the talk and said,
we're big fans,
we'd really like to work with you.
And I was like,
Eh,
sure.
I mean,
I know you guys are up to some cool.
I admire it.
And I took like eight weeks to set up the meeting and by then the benchmark guys
had done that deal.
That's again,
oh my God,
I can't imagine how much money we,
we've left on the table as a result of that.
So,
um,
you know,
I like to say when I'm wrong,
I'm wrong.
And when I'm writing I'm really,
really right.
And
the question on being wrong though,
I'm very curious about this.
And uh,
just coming back to kind of the poker analysis or analogy rather,
the,
and actually heard about this at in depth in,
at first when I became friends with some hedge fund managers and they really try
to focus on good process and not conflating say bad outcomes with bad process.
In other words,
you did I make the right decision at the time,
even if I missed out a huge opportunity
because you can also say pick a company for the wrong reasons and have a
fantastic outcome.
But over time if you develop bad habits,
it can really screw you.
Right?
So do you,
do you think that you made the wrong decision with those companies,
uh,
in terms of the analysis of the process that you followed?
Or did you make the right decision based on your rules you've set up for
yourself and you just missed,
missed out on a few opportunities but also hit some home runs?
The one thing that all those failures to invest,
um,
that they all have in common is that I let the negative case dominate my
analysis of whether I should invest or not.
So
in the beginning and the,
in as a seed stage investor,
you don't really get a lot of data,
right?
Right.
We don't have any financials.
They'll look at,
the team usually consists of three to five people.
There's some users,
but not enough at scale.
They're usually just the early adopters.
So you don't know whether it's going to be a big thing yet.
So you don't have a massive diligence process.
And so a lot of what you're going on as your gut about this product and about
this team,
and I think the easiest way to screw this up is to let the negative case
dominate your perspective.
So Dropbox,
I'm thinking about the competitive landscape and I'm thinking,
okay,
Google is going to crush them.
Well,
first of all,
we've seen that didn't actually happen and rarely does the incumbent crush
anybody.
It's just not that common.
A startup is going to move much faster than a division of a company where it's
not their bread and butter.
I mean g drive spent three years in Beta,
you know,
internal Beta,
et cetera.
It was never really a priority for them.
So course Dropbox is going to win that.
You know,
I look at Airbnb,
yes,
there's going to be bad things that happen,
like people get,
their apartment's trashed,
you know,
from time to time.
But somehow I let that distract me from the potential for this worldwide
marketplace for space that was just going to displace hotels with snapchat.
I'm thinking about Dick Pics and you know how it's being used by that was on the
pro side.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like,
Hey,
uh,
but no,
I'm thinking about like it's lame content.
Uh,
it's being used poorly by like junior high girls and stuff like that who were
exposing themselves and they're just,
they're bad
or bad examples of how snapchat wasn't necessarily a helpful thing.
And again,
I like to be proud of my deals.
On the other hand,
you see today it is just to network with a hundreds of millions of users who are
building incredibly valuable content,
you know,
with the launch of stories and discover and stuff like that.
But I got distracted.
I let the,
I let the downside and negative case a way,
the risk and yet,
you know,
you like you look at Uber,
Uber could,
if it was easy enough to say no to Uber because like,
ah,
the taxis are the regulation in the lobby or these drivers are going to hurt
people at some point.
And somehow I was able to look past all that and when nobody else in the valley
wanted to and get that deal done.
Um,
what's,
what I think is,
is really interesting about Uber in particular is,
uh,
and
for those people who don't know him,
that of,
uh,
early advisor Uber.
So I'm biased obviously and a lot of ways when it talk about it,
but I think you actually got there before me.
Yeah.
It was pre pre seed money advisor because I'd been to advisor,
stumble upon it,
had worked with Garrett and uh,
I'm now working,
uh,
again collaborating with him on expo,
which is Super Fun.
But in the beginning,
the way that Uber got dismissed,
and I think this is a really common,
uh,
common mistake it seems that a lot of investors make is people said,
oh my God,
really like black cars for one percenters in San Francisco.
What's the market for that?
And they,
they viewed a very niche activity is by definition constrained to say 1% or is
in San Francisco,
in New York.
Um,
and the,
if you look at,
let's say even recycling,
it started out that way and they kind of confuse the first target with the total
market.
And they also looked at just the available market,
which they misdefined um,
very early on and didn't,
uh,
you know,
in the case of like an airbnb or an Uber,
they can grow the market of beyond any comparable that's available.
Um,
so in any case,
but the uh,
I mean a lot of these start off so incredibly niche that people misread the
market potential I think.
But let me ask you a question about the getting,
focusing on the,
the positive scenarios and the,
the potential high multiple outcomes because for those people who aren't
familiar with venture capital,
it's a,
it's a term that comes up a lot in magazines and media coverage is very hot
right now.
Um,
so the,
you explained it in brief,
but the,
it's a fair to say that two and 20 is a pretty fair way to think about it in
terms of the,
I mean not everybody,
but that's like how people talk about venture capital and hedge funds and so on.
You have this management fee and then you have the carry,
which is kind of your split.
But what,
what I wonder is,
do you think vcs should not think about the downside as much as the upside
because they're only the rewarded on the upside and not on the downside.
Whereas say hedge fund investors can have long short bets and think more about
when I hang out with like hedge fund guys versus say a venture capitalist or
Vcs,
the hedge fund guys are many of them,
much more kind of apocalyptic and their thinking.
Um,
and it would seem like that is tied to their ability to make money from a lot of
those catastrophes.
I mean those,
those guys can be short.
And in fact,
even if the apocalypse isn't really approaching,
they'll still get people to write articles about the impending apocalypse for
those companies to make sure that it's a self fulfilling prophecy.
Yeah.
What,
so,
so what are,
what are the biggest differences in your mind between the top say venture
capitalists and Hedge Fund guys and private equity guys or,
Oh yeah.
How that,
how do they differ if they do or what do they have in common?
Is we were talking about at lunch,
first of all,
everyone I know on Wall Street is just jacked on stimulants all day long.
So they're taking provigil,
they're doing rails.
They,
uh,
those guys just in such an incredibly
competitive environment that they're using every chemical edge they can find.
That's definitely not happening in the VC set.
Uh,
the VC life demands kind of a much more steady reflective state.
There's certainly obviously moments of negotiation and in standoffs,
but it's,
it's much more of a thought in emotional intelligence exercise.
Um,
you know,
that said,
because the valley silicon valley,
so kind of built on positive energy and love U.
Dot.
V what ends up happening is as the stakes have gotten higher,
the funds have gotten bigger.
The industries more flush with capital.
It's more competitive than ever.
And a friend of mine who I've done some work with WHO's on the east coast and
the private equity world,
since the main difference between New York and San Francisco is out here in New
York,
we stab each other in the eye,
face to face.
And uh,
and out there you guys just cut the other guy's Achilles and let them bleed out.
Well,
while looking at him,
you know,
it's just,
uh,
it's incredible how I think in,
in the San Francisco world,
we,
we really try and maintain these longterm friendships.
We try and build these reputations that will scale over time.
Cause it's a venture capitalist.
You're raising money on a every three years basically and it's a 10 year fund
and you know,
you're,
you're hoping to have a long tenure in the,
in the industry with great relationships that you can draw on to recruit people
in your portfolio,
companies that you can use to help your portfolio companies raise more money,
go public or get sold.
And because of the fact that we're big equity holders who only get paid back
upon an ultimate exit maybe eight,
10 years from now,
we tend to act more with that in mind.
That longterm perspective,
guys I work with on the east coast have much shorter timeframes,
right?
They're much more used to quarter by quarter analysis of a public company.
Um,
Hey,
do you have any news today?
You know,
they,
and it's,
it's very,
very near term and they don't have the stomach for the ups and downs of building
this stuff over time.
And so it's a,
it's great.
They're,
you know,
they're living on by a different report card than we are.
Yeah.
So that's the biggest thing.
You know,
we,
there are other businesses like this,
like the media business as a cash quarterly business.
You go to a media company,
you go to a record label or movies studio you and say,
let's do an equity deal.
And they laugh in your face and like how much revenue are you going to guarantee
in year one because that's how they get paid.
Right.
All those executives are on annual contracts and they've got payments.
They still own their houses in the Hamptons and they're just like,
I'm not going to walk away from that guaranteed cash right now.
Sorry,
I'm breaking because you're laughing right there.
I know it's taken your,
no,
no.
This is good.
I W no,
I wonder if that could also be related to the fact that St Silicon Valley,
it's such a small world and you work very hard to get to a point where you a
deal flow meaning opportunities that come to you that are of a sort of pre
filtered,
high quality,
right?
Uh,
whereas in a lot of these other spaces,
they're going out and using analysts to sort of hunt for opportunities that
other people have not exploited.
Um,
so I mean,
it's humans responding to incentives,
right?
In a way.
Well,
in a hedge fund environment,
you're working with public stocks,
usually at arm's length.
You might try and go activist and get on the board.
You might try to,
like I alluded to change the press cycle.
Um,
but you know,
for the most part you're doing analysis at arm's length of these companies and
the private equity world,
there's a business already there,
right?
There's a,
there are products or multiple products.
There's financials,
their supply chain.
And so you're going in and saying,
I can do a better job of this than you can.
And so there's an arm's length and there's some tension obviously with
management.
Usually sometimes you're coopting members that management team to go get it
done.
But the venture world is different in that
it's much earlier and it's much more where the venture capitalist is a
collaborator in determining the product and the strategy and the vector of the
business is going to take.
And so there has to be a much more collaborative approach over the longterm to
go ahead and actually build this company.
So there's nothing,
you know,
and I think there are certainly venture capitalists who maybe come out of the
world of finance or have a different perspective that they,
their job is just to sit on the outside and tell somebody how to run a business.
That's,
that's the private equity model.
But it's a real early stage venture capitalists.
You're job is to sit in the room and actually work at the Beck and call of the
CEO to get stuff done to help build this company,
lend advice about product strategy,
about go to market,
about the design of the front page,
how to staff up and bring in the next couple of members of the team,
how to go about raising money,
how to deal with your first PR cycles.
And so that I think brings a much different person and the successful niche,
not necessarily the biggest,
um,
you know,
self promoter,
not necessarily the most widely known person,
et cetera.
But somebody who actually can hustle to go ahead.
And as we go back to what we talked to earlier,
to tip the balance from something that's good to do,
being totally awesome,
being great.
What,
what books or resources outside of personal relationships and these mentors that
you've had,
the complements and so on,
are there any particular
books or resources that have helped you become a better investor?
Yeah,
I think most of those though are not business books per se.
Perfect.
That's great.
Guys.
Um,
so I didn't get a business to guiding and then do an Mba.
I took a couple of classes and it was enough to show me it was a total farce.
Um,
I did get a law degree,
which isn't even bigger farce,
but that's for another episode.
So,
so I never had formal business training and so I don't really,
and,
and I tried to look at
a few of those like instant MBA books and stuff like that.
I even bought some books on venture capital and they're just such a,
so goofy and law.
And by the way,
part of that is because now we have so many great venture capitalists bloggers
who are just an open book about the industry who teach it.
So Brad Feld comes to mind first,
a longtime friend and mentor,
uh,
Brad at Feld thoughts,
you know,
has done series over the years where he breaks down each aspect of a term sheet,
how to understand it and the deal documents.
And this is what we think is important in these are things we think could go
away.
Uh,
Josh Copperman,
his team have done a lot of work on that.
We've now seen y Combinator and the guys at Fenwick and West and Cooley building
templated documents that are really,
really watered down and pro entrepreneur and just kind of have,
have taken out a lot of the legacy bullshit that didn't need to be in those
documents.
And so there's a lot of this learning that can happen now without having to buy
books.
And while that happened to go to school and so that's been fantastic.
But where I worry about the valley and about investors as well as our
entrepreneurs is in the development of everything off the ball a little bit.
So you know,
you and I,
I just turned 40 this week.
That's why you're here.
Happy Birthday again.
But,
but as a 40 year old,
the people my age who were computer science majors in college,
they,
that was a major,
just like any other major,
they still had to go get a summer job.
They mowed lawns,
waited tables,
uh,
they had time in their curriculum to go study abroad to volunteer.
They had these really well rounded lives.
And so working with people my age and older at Google who are computer
scientists was great because they had,
uh,
not just these amazing,
amazing math and science skills,
but a diversity of experience that informed great product decisions as well as
just collegiality.
What ended up happening is computer science degrees got so popular and so
valuable that those kids didn't have to pay for school much anymore.
You know,
and they're only work experience was like ta in a class,
not actually getting their ass kicked digging ditches or anything.
And the curriculum was,
Reagan are rigorous enough that these guys didn't get to go study abroad and
there was no opportunity to go do volunteer work and live in the developing
world at all.
And so as a result,
I actually found we were starting to have a generation of not just entitled and
you know,
people talk about the entitlement of the millennials and when it comes to work
ethic and stuff,
but they weren't just entitled,
but they just had such narrow band perspectives on the world.
They were missing empathy.
So they weren't able to put themselves in the shoes of the folks.
They might be building a product for what the problems of a world might be.
And so I am constantly looking for opportunities for myself and for the founders
that we work with to,
to broaden the scope that they have on the world such that they can build
something on a more informed basis and emotionally informed basis.
So,
I mean,
I,
I really think empathy is,
and it's,
it's a word that's been kind of reduced to signal like,
oh,
somebody,
uh,
you know,
somebody hurt their foot and I feel bad for them.
Uh,
instead,
I think much more poignantly empathy is about can I see the world through that
person's Lens?
Can I figure out what matters to them?
What are they afraid of?
What's bothering them?
What do they think is limiting them right now?
What's their hope?
And if I can do that,
then it's a lot easier for me to build something for them and to sell it to them
and to help them and to build a longer term partnership with that person.
If you were giving a
assignment to folks for books or experiences,
just kind of a short list for people who want to develop that type of empathy,
what would you put on the list?
One of my favorite books that we give to most founders is,
I'm not fade away.
Uh,
I think it's like I'll eat slop pick on the cover.
Yeah.
I belly flop.
Pick a short life.
Well lived story of Peter Barton,
uh,
that it's the,
first of all,
just on a personal note,
that guy's trajectory kind of followed mine.
He was a ski bum who suddenly made a big attack.
He was on the border,
Yahoo.
He worked at liberty media.
Uh,
and then he hits his forties and says,
okay,
I've accomplished what I want to accomplish.
I'm dialing it back.
I just want to spend time with my family.
And at that point,
and this isn't a spoiler,
it's literally how the book starts.
He finds out it is incurable stomach cancer.
And so the book walks,
uh,
walks you through his biography as well as the remaining time in his life.
Uh,
you will cry reading this book.
It is inevitable.
If you don't,
I'm very worried about you,
but you'll definitely cry.
It will be Cathartic.
But it's the kind of thing where you,
it's,
it's an exercise in,
okay,
what's on the mind of the person who's dying
and how is he thinking about the impact of his death on his family,
on his friends,
on his business,
partners,
on his legacy,
on the continuing responsibilities as a dad,
even in the absence of,
you know,
even though he's passed on in the next life.
And it,
it's an entire exercise and perspectives and I think that book will not only
leave you feeling incredibly lucky for what we've got here and where we are,
but at the same time,
um,
we'll,
we'll sharpen that,
that,
that sense of how do I put myself in somebody else's shoes,
a similar book that I love.
It's,
I,
I'm going to get the title wrong.
I think it's how to get filthy rich in rising Asia,
I think is going to be,
you told me about this book isn't me.
So it's written in the second person,
which I don't know of another book like that.
But it's just you,
you,
you like,
you wake up in this room almost like an old,
like an old role player or something like that online,
like dungeons and dragons.
If it is reading to you are in a room,
there's a sarcophagus,
open sarcophagus,
no,
it's a,
but it says,
you know,
you wake up and you basically start the book in a slum in Pakistan and it's just
writing to you about how you go through your day and the things that matter to
you.
And it turns out you're kind of entrepreneurial and you're willing to take some
risks.
And so you start working into other stations in life.
And I don't want to give anything else about the book away,
but you close that book and you feel like you've,
you've walked through 15 to 20 different lives and another world.
And I just think more of that would be better for all of us.
I think it'd be better for our industry,
for the depth and the impact of the products we build.
I think just be a lot better for getting along with each other.
So,
I mean,
you and I have traveled to Ethiopia together doing work with charity water.
It's hard to complain about a day's work back here in the United States when you
have being in a village where they walk three to four hours each way to get
water where the kids are dying because they drink the same water that the cow,
uh,
poops into,
where the women don't get an opportunity to go to school because they're
carrying the water and on the way they might get eaten by a lion or raped.
And it's,
it's really hard to find yourself complaining about are privileged us life.
And,
um,
and that's something you could just tell.
We're in a big company like Google.
They were the people who would bitch and complain.
And I'm like,
really?
It really,
this is a hard day.
Microsoft launch a competitive product and that's our,
that's our horrible day.
And I just think we'd all be much better off if we were able to find
opportunities for our CS students to go study abroad for,
for our MBA is to actually spend some time around poor people.
Um,
and,
and to start building these more diverse perspectives.
Uh,
would you look back on,
since it's a,
since it's the big Foro,
when you were 30,
uh,
who came to mind most when you thought of the word successful?
And now at 40,
who is the person who most comes to mind when you think of the word successful?
Right.
So 30.
That's a really,
I got,
let me think of where I was.
So I guess,
oh,
I was at Google at the time.
Um,
who is most successful?
It's just when you were like,
I want to be successful in the person,
in your mind who embodied that most.
Yeah.
I always wanted to be at the center of the deal.
And so at that point in my life,
I still really admired,
for instance,
uh,
like a John Doerr or Mike Moritz,
they were both on the board at Google,
brilliant guys who use their station in life to gather even smarter people to
teach them about things.
And then they would use their unique talents for storytelling and,
and making composite kind of ideas come true to build companies.
They became as a result,
um,
the head great families,
they were just well respected by folks.
I think I still,
um,
that was kind of my definition of success at that point,
uh,
at 40 and what I think my journey from 30 to 40 was about was to stop trying to
define or,
or,
or build some kind of model or have some kind of role model out there and start
to it.
Stop trying to define myself externally because that's a distraction.
So there are times when you're doing a deal with John Doerr,
you're across the table or someone you're like,
hey wait,
that was fucked up.
You know,
like,
I don't wait,
you're supposed to be my hero,
my idol and I don't like that move you just made or something like that.
Right.
And I think,
you know,
anyone I've ever put on a pedestal,
I've just been disappointed by doing so.
Um,
I'm sorry about that by the way.
Oh,
you have no var,
no idea how far you fall into him.
But,
but so I think for me the,
the exercise has been how much am I going to define that for myself,
not by looking at somebody else.
I recently got to have dinner with next to Bill Gates,
Bill and Melinda Gates and I had been raised to hate him,
you know,
growing up at Google,
he's,
he's a pretty evil person and I was sitting next in there and I got a chance to
basically interview him about how they have structured the foundation,
how they think about which causes to take on which challenges to tackle.
And I mean,
I walked out of there just deeply admiring their work,
but I think I want to limit it to that and not get into like,
is he a great family man?
Is He,
you know,
he's still a son of a bitch when it comes to competing with him and software and
his default browser knows the antitrust behavior.
But,
uh,
but I really,
I'm trying to look at people and find kind of one aspect of them that I like,
but for the most part I've had to decide,
okay,
what's really important to me?
Um,
that's my wife and my kids and,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I'm just not that social anymore.
I just don't hang out with people that much.
I don't go to conferences,
I'm just not available for dinner.
I would infimately rather spend that time with them.
And so that was a priority choice I had to make internally,
not because I saw anybody else killing it that way.
You know,
I think I reflected back on my own parents who,
who opted out of much more accelerated career path so they could spend way more
time with me and my brother.
And,
uh,
and so that's a choice I had to me.
But I will say,
do you know about the,
the journal I found in my life?
And you should,
you should mention that I have a quick,
well observation is if I could spend more time with crystal instead of me,
I would do the same thing.
Uh,
we actually met before you and I met at fairtex kickboxing.
We back in the day.
Well yeah,
I was,
so I was having some,
I was having a bunch of people down for cocktails.
We came down from Truckee into the city,
crystal and I did,
I was like,
let's get a bunch of people together for cocktails.
I invite Tim and Tim walks in and he looks at my girlfriend.
He's like,
I think I know him.
I'm like,
yeah,
sure you do man.
Everyone uses that to try and pick up my then girlfriend now wife.
And he's like,
no.
And then she says,
yeah,
I think I know you too.
And I'm,
Oh shit,
here she goes like I'm going to,
where's this going?
He's such a honk.
What do I have to offer to?
But uh,
yeah,
you guys used to,
you guys used to train and kickboxing.
Yeah,
she was hardcore.
It was always,
but um,
I want to pause for a second.
The,
the,
I do want to hear about the notebook for sure.
Cause I think it's amazingly Nostradamus like,
but the um,
you and your brother,
so your brother have had very different careers,
have done very well respectively.
What did your parents do that you are also trying to do with your kids?
Yes.
So my brother Brian Saca,
he's on the first youtube sketch stars.
Um,
he parlayed that into,
he sold some of the first web series ever,
made a shit ton of money building web series and finding commercial partners for
them and stuff.
Uh,
if this beautiful movies like yeah,
Wolf of Wall Street,
Wall Street with Scorsese recently.
Um,
and then just yesterday are allowed to talk about this now.
He,
his,
his series on TBS got picked up.
So he's going to be a Costar of a comedy series on TBS.
Pretty funny thing.
Um,
so what did our parents do?
Well,
first of all,
they were just always involved.
So my parents took vacations with us.
We always went to national parks together.
Uh,
we never went to resort type places.
We were just always together and you know,
not only are they read with us,
like most parents,
but my mom would pull us out of school to take us to go see an author,
read,
you know,
at a,
at a bookstore,
an hour and a half away.
She would literally just pull us out of school to go to a science museum.
And so she was a college professor.
And so she had a little flexibility in her schedule to yank us out.
She would take us to a park called art park.
Uh,
I've been loosed in New York,
Art Park,
art park.
It's a state park in New York state and loosen New York where the whole thing is
dedicated to different,
uh,
art media.
And so you can paint there,
you can blow glass,
you can watch a performing arts truth kind of Vaudevillian theater and stuff.
And,
and my parents eyes,
that was just as,
or even maybe more important than going to the public school.
And so I think that kind of enrichment and,
and just being shown that people in all these walks of life were important and
fascinating.
You know,
I grew up where by the time I got to college,
I had never heard of an investment banker.
I didn't know that was a job.
Um,
you know,
I'd,
I'd been exposed to,
to writers,
to artists,
to chefs,
to musicians,
to engineers,
to lots of teachers,
to lawyers,
to doctors.
Um,
but it was never,
you know,
it wasn't necessarily driven in any,
in any particular way to kind of get us to a particular career at all.
I will say there was something else my parents did that's pretty unique and it
was called,
uh,
my brother and I referred to as a sweet and sour summer.
So my parents would send us for the,
sounds like a Chinese restaurant.
They would,
yeah,
they sentence for the first half of this summer to an internship with a relative
or friend of the family who had an interesting job.
So at,
I went and interned with a,
uh,
my God brother who was a lobbyist in DC.
So I would go along with him to pitch congressmen.
I had one tie and you know,
for,
for work I would,
I was a pretty good writer.
So I write up one page summaries of the bills we were pitching and I would
literally sit there with these congressmen,
with these filthy miles,
you know,
the Alabama senator and stuff like that.
And uh,
and watch the pitch happened and it was awesome.
I learned so much.
I think I built so much confidence and really honed my storytelling skills.
But then from there we'd come home and work in a construction outfit,
uh,
with just a nasty,
nasty job.
I mean,
whether it was hosing off the equipment that had been used to fix septic
systems,
you know,
gas and shit up dragging shit around the yard,
filling propane tanks,
just being junior guy on the totem told them quite literally getting my ass
kicked by over whichever parolee was angry at me that day.
Uh,
you know,
for minimum wage,
I think it was part of their master plan,
which is there's a world of cool opportunities out there for you.
But let's build within you a sense of not just work ethic but also a little kick
in the ass by why you don't want to end up in one of these real jobs.
And so let's see if you can find in yourself the drive to go and do whatever it
is to,
and did they choose,
for instance,
you had the introduction to save you the,
uh,
the God brother,
I think you said for the lobbying.
Did they also help organize the sour part to teach summer?
Yeah.
So that the guy ran that construction company and equipment rental companies.
My Dad's best friend,
and he was under strict orders to make sure we had the roughest day there,
a special treatment.
It was w we,
yeah,
we were treated specially shittily so we were,
we were hammered there.
Uh,
and,
and by the way,
as a result,
I know a lot about construction equipment.
This is,
this is a super power of mine.
Uh,
I can literally from air compressors to ditch witches to anything you need and
Milwaukee saws all,
I literally have incredible amounts of knowledge in that space.
But also just reminded me of something you mentioned long ago and I'm not sure
if it's still true,
but you said one of the things that you look for,
and it's maybe not a disqualifier,
but in founders is uh,
a track record of having had at least one shitty job.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
Well I'd mix particular look for that in hiring.
So,
uh,
I want people who've lived,
studied,
traveled extensively abroad.
Uh,
I want people who have been exposed to poor people.
And by the way,
the live study travel works densely abroad is because you can get away with a
very comfortable life in the United States as an English speaker,
particularly as a white person,
you never really have to ask for anybody's help.
You're not being perhaps harassed by the police.
It's pretty easy.
Pickins you find yourself overseas,
particularly in a place with a non romance language where you can't make out the
signs yourself and you have to stop and ask for help from complete strangers.
You literally have to be entirely vulnerable to people you've never met and just
expose yourself and they could send you into a dark alley and beat the Heidi you
and take your money.
Or like most people on the planet,
there'll be really nice and head and tried to help you even if you don't share a
word of English in common.
And I think there is something incredibly foreigner about that experience of
having the humility that comes from having asked for help.
You know,
the best managers in the world are people who are great at asking for help and
realizing that makes them a more powerful CEO then the less powerful CEO or more
powerful managers than Alessy powerful manager.
And so I looked for people for whom athletics is a big part of their life.
I don't think it needs to be team sports necessarily.
I think you can,
uh,
you can be,
a great individual athlete,
you know,
maybe you train with other folks,
et Cetera.
But I think it just shows,
uh,
not only some self discipline but also just a value on the introspection that
comes with athletics.
You actually care about yourself.
I think there's a little bit more balanced in that life.
It also teaches you to contend with losing and sort of viewing that as feedback
and not some type of failure.
Death sentence.
Sure.
And then seeing,
I think the temporary and it me a temporary pain is,
you know,
and that's temporary.
Gloria's forever.
No,
it's true.
So I mean,
I remember when I did an Ironman and when I was,
when I was doing that and the,
and I had,
I had a fever that day,
I don't know,
103 degree fever,
but my parents had traveled out to watch the race.
And so I didn't want to not do it.
And the Advil worked for like the swim and the first part of the bike.
And then I was just,
I was a mess.
But I remember thinking,
no matter what happens,
I will be in my bed tonight.
And you know,
this is a very,
very temporary moment.
In 2009,
I rode my bike across the country and I remember,
you know,
it was 35 days of riding,
basically a hundred miles a day.
I remember multiple days out there and I'm like,
I'll be in my bed tonight.
And then in the other ear is his voice.
And then I have to fucking do it again tomorrow.
Um,
I'm going to pull out a couple of random ones,
but,
uh,
what historical figure do you most identify with Buckminster Fuller?
Why?
And maybe you could give some context for people who don't know,
who don't recognize buggy.
So Bucky is,
I mean there,
I have a feeling if we went to his Wikipedia page,
there'd be a paragraph of,
of nouns describing the skies and mathematician.
He was a philosopher,
he was an engineer,
he was a poet.
He's a lecturer,
a teacher,
he's an inventor,
a futurist.
Uh,
he,
he's one of the few people you will find that is willing to write the optimistic
case for technology that,
that all this stuff isn't leading us to dystopia.
That we actually are busting Malthus,
the Malthusian kind of quandary wide open and we now have the resources to feed
everyone,
clothe everyone,
power everything without having to dig.
I mean the guys,
he passed away 30 years ago now,
but um,
but there is an optimism to everything he writes there that these machines
aren't here to take over,
that humans are good at heart.
And there's something really inspiring about that is we wrestle with some of
these big scary issues about the power of
the Internet too.
You know,
we,
periscope gets launched in the first week.
I'm getting questions from reporters about well,
can't isis use this to rally people?
And you're like,
seriously,
that's the part you're going to focus on a periscope.
Like all of the amazing uses for periscope,
which I think is absolutely groundbreaking technology and really,
really cool.
And people are so focused on that negative case.
And you had the same time.
I think Paris can be used to inspire,
educate.
He'll bring people together across so many different planes that it's easy to
get distracted by that negative case.
But I think Bucky more than anyone I know found optimism and the stuff that
could otherwise be
pretty daunting.
He also didn't he also create a,
it's not geodesic,
that's not the word I'm looking for.
The domes.
Yeah,
the sphere.
Your district domes.
Isaac dumps that you see people constructing at burning man.
Yeah.
Fascinating guy.
Um,
in the Bucky ball and the Bucky ball.
Really interesting dude.
Also.
Uh,
uh,
what was the concept?
It was really,
I'm axiom there were more there.
There's some type of tensegrity 10 Segretti which good,
good man.
So this,
this concept of 10 Segretti I'm not going to do it,
do it justice,
but it,
there were some really interesting parallels between his discussion of this
concept of tensegrity and the role of Fascia within the body.
Because if you didn't have fashion,
I mean your organs are basically just dropped down to the bottom of your like
Tor forso cavity and just sit there in a pool of,
of nasty meat.
But you have this Fascia that holds you together.
A super,
super interesting guy.
Uh,
completely agreed.
Did you collect anything when you were,
when you were a kid
and then we need to talk about your notebook.
Yeah,
I mean I collected money so I'll have to money.
I mean I was just,
Oh,
I always wanted to make money.
It just,
I do the backstroke like uncle scrooge and the pool of coins.
Yeah.
Excuse me.
I scratch my monocle swearing through.
Right room full of gold coins.
No,
I,
I was a hustler from day one.
I grew up middle class so we never had wants of anything,
but I always thought there would be a certain independence that came with money.
I was certain excitement that came with making money.
And so from the earliest days I would you ever seen the,
like those pungent walnuts that come out of a tree,
they've got that green,
pungent skin on them.
And if you,
if you pierce it with a fork,
it smells like ammonia salad.
Grab those things out of our yard,
putting my wagon,
pierce holes and all of them.
Then I build a sign that says air fresheners,
25 cents in it.
Like I'd put it on my brother,
like a sandwich board,
my younger brother and I tow it up and down the street and sell these things
door to door and all the people would call my parents and just picked,
do you know where your son is?
But they'd still by him it's like clear like three,
four bucks,
come home,
richest,
you know,
Richard's six year old and the neighborhood and uh,
I just love that hustle.
I was always going after something.
Is that something you were just pre programmed to do or did your parents
facilitate that?
It's not,
it's not either my parents game at all.
Like they were notes.
I mean my mom is a really accomplished professor and author in the field of
education.
My Dad is incredible small town lawyer who frankly could have made a lot more
money but was constantly doing pro bono work for people in our town.
He's incredibly revered person with so much goodwill,
and so neither of them were,
were hustlers like that,
but I was always looking for the angle.
So movie,
did you watch like the toy or what was their trading places?
Was there a trigger or training plays a good movie?
No,
I mean,
I will say,
you know,
I traded baseball cards despite not liking baseball at all.
I never watched any games,
but like that 86,
87 Don Resi or the 85 tops,
you know,
it can Seiko rookies and the Roger Clemens rookies that Mark McGuire Olympic
card from 84,
like,
I was really into those things because I was good at it and I could make money
doing it later.
I realized that was really good at playing cards too.
So I played a lot of cards.
I ran a card room in my high school,
one of my teachers.
What type of card games?
We talked,
uh,
we were playing a lot of [inaudible],
which is a game that's only played in New Orleans and Lockport,
New York.
Uh,
it's a really high stakes geometrically growing pot game.
And so,
uh,
you can really,
you can get Scutter fools and so especially if you're teaching them the rules,
a lot of that,
a lot of hearts,
a lot of bid pitch,
a lot of ac DC and just really street games that,
and we had a teacher who took a rake.
Uh,
I had him,
I had them on the take so we could,
uh,
he could write passes so people get to the card room,
but I always kind of just had to hustle.
And I got how old was that?
How old were you?
Uh,
I did that.
I started that in junior high.
Uh,
one of our friends.
What does this teacher teach?
What was their subject?
No,
one of our friends,
his mom was a teacher and so she had an office.
So we got to use the office as the card room.
That was more easy to see back then.
It wasn't a really cerebral game.
Uh,
but again,
it had the progressive pot type stuff in high school.
It was my,
is my cross country coach and a in American history teacher,
Mr Maine,
he was a gem and I was that guy.
He just knew that I wasn't cut out for public high school.
And so he,
he really helped me see,
you've also,
you've always had this hustle.
Uh,
I want to,
I have to ask and if you want to Perry,
this one feel free,
but so I've heard these rumors that you got through law school without going to
any classes.
Yeah.
Well I,
if I,
if you go to class then they've got your name on the seating chart.
Yeah.
The first day you have to sign a seating chart.
It goes around and then he'd sit in the same seat everyday in law school.
But if you don't go to class and her name's not on the seating chart and so they
can't call on you and realize you're not going to class.
And so instead you go to the exams and the exams are just printed off the
registrar's role.
Right.
Sued and that the teacher of the class isn't there,
so you just sit down for the exam and if you're a good test taker you can kill
it.
And I was amazing.
I had some of the best grades in my law school.
How did you,
How did York Street,
that was the method to the mat?
Well,
the funny thing is unlike any other college class or Mba class,
what's taught in the classroom in law school a has nothing to do with being a
lawyer and be has very little to even do with the exam.
It's,
it's such a joke man.
The Socratic method and stuff like that.
I think there are some people who need to be taught to think linearly,
you know,
pro con,
pro con.
But I think by that point I and my roommate,
Kevin Cody,
who you've met,
you know,
we're already their own brainer brainer capital was the year ahead of us at
Georgetown law school and he helped us realize this method.
He was like the Tim Ferriss at Georgetown law school.
He helped us understand what was important,
what wasn't.
Um,
and it,
you know,
in my heart of hearts,
I wasn't really there to be a lawyer.
I think if I'd want it to be a litigator,
if I really wanted to go try things before the Supreme Court,
I think going to law school and actually attending classes and interacting
would've been a great exercise.
I went there because I thought it was my fastest path to a seat at the table in
Silicon Valley.
I wanted to be in the middle of a deal and,
and have people listen to me even though they probably shouldn't cause I had
very limited experience,
but I want it to be in the Maelstrom.
And I knew that if I went and got to kick ass a lot of you with great grades,
I could end up at a kickass law firm in Silicon Valley and via guy who at 25,
26 they were going to listen to where else does that happen?
So,
uh,
so that was the path.
But yeah,
I kicked ass in.
What school?
Without going to any,
I will say this,
I,
you might've heard the legend,
but,
uh,
so the,
the thing that you do need are some notes from some of the classes to understand
like which cases the,
the professor brought up and what they think is important.
And so,
uh,
I threw a keg party every semester where the only thing you had to bring to get
into the party where your notes,
so classmates would bring their notes to the party,
throw them in a Bin,
and then I would go to xerox and mall and,
and build kind of a composite and use that to study for the exams as the
cheeses.
And the,
the notebook that you found not too long ago,
this all tracks together,
but we're approaching it and kind of a memento type fashion that the notebook
until people about this notebook.
Yeah,
it was funny.
I was just,
just two years ago,
I found this in my garage and it's really,
it's been weighing on me in particularly this week,
turning 40.
So I was 19 and I was 20 years old.
Actually,
I was 20.
I was living in Ireland.
Uh,
going to school there.
I spent two out of my four years abroad while at the school of foreign service
at Georgetown and some living in Ireland and there was an ex pat girl and one of
my classes and we were basically flirting with each other by taking a notebook
and writing in 10 questions for the other person to answer and then you get,
you get it back and you answer 10 questions and write 10 new questions.
We pass back and forth while we're supposed to be studying like 20th century
Irish film or something like that.
And at 1.1 of the questions was what do you want to be when you grow up?
Some 20 I'm living in Cork,
Ireland.
We basically would start drinking stout around 11:30 AM every day.
It was like second and third meal with Stout and by that point I'd still never
heard of an investment banker.
I definitely never heard of venture capitalists and so I just write in there.
I said,
I don't know what the,
what the job is called,
but I know it's going to involve a lot of talking on the phone a lot in
negotiating,
a lot of yelling at people,
high risk,
high reward,
unbelievably high stakes.
I'm going to do it part time from the mountains parttime from the beach and
whatever it is.
I'm going to be done with it before I'm 40 and so two years ago my wife and I
are standing in our garage and our mountain house cleaning it out because we're
moving some stuff down to our beach house and I find this old notebook and I'm
like,
hey look at this and we're flipping through it and I find that answer I guess
really choked up.
It was incredibly weird self prophecy that I kind of laid out exactly what my
job was,
but I also felt a certain amount of pressure like so what do I do now?
I'm 42,
I keep doing this job or not.
Or do I need to,
do I need to listen to the scrolls,
like shatter some type of cosmic continuum if you,
if you don't follow the prophecy the um,
so you do spend a lot of time on the phone or you have historically clearly very
good storyteller.
What are the,
what are the words or phrases that you overuse the most?
The words or phrases that I overused the most amazing bananas.
Cocoa nuts.
It's cocoa nuts.
A close cousin to bananas.
Yeah,
that is coco nuts up.
I use the phrase that said a lot as a transition.
You know,
transition words are really important for me because having,
I know you've studied how to learn other languages.
One of the things I always focused on when studying and I speak Spanish was,
was transition where it's like seen him about her go.
Like nevertheless,
you know,
like I needed,
I needed to have those transition words down cause that's how I could tell a
good story.
That's how I would lay out.
We're a new paragraph.
Even if you haven't been following me.
I got a new concept coming and,
and I really think studying it that way and bringing it back.
I used to live in Spain,
in Ecuador,
El Salvador.
I'm bringing that back to my English and I realized I'm really clear about my
transition where it's now so hard return.
That's it.
Yeah.
But I am,
I mean you can ask Matt Mazzeo my partner,
you know,
we write updates to our investors that no other fun does.
Like we write deep,
colorful narrative about all of our investments,
the state of our companies,
a state of the industry,
our own personal states,
what we're thinking about.
And by the time you see one of those as an investor,
I probably edited that thing like Os you know,
draft 15 to 20 times.
I'm obsessive about writing.
It needs to be crisp,
original,
no repetition of words and phrases.
I need to bring it.
And that was something I got directly from my parents who were both exceptional
writers.
But I think in,
in colloquial terms,
when we're talking with people,
I try and emulate whatever the language pattern is or the person I'm talking to,
it makes them feel better.
I don't even think I'd do it consciously.
Like,
you come to an island like this,
it's staffed all by Brits and you can't help but suddenly find you're ours
getting a little bit funny and you're like,
okay,
hold off.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
but I think that's something I really try and focus on is speaking in the same
speed as the person I'm talking to.
You seem to have had a very clear picture as reflected in the notebook and
obviously the early hustle you had this drive that seem to point of very
particular direction.
I know that when I was about to graduate from college,
I had no idea of what my next move was and law school hadn't even entered,
uh,
the sort of realm of consideration.
What would your advice be to college students who are just about to graduate,
who have no idea,
kind of what they should focus on,
which what they should do.
Do you have any,
any thoughts going to general suggestions that you would make to someone in that
position?
Well,
I did give a graduation speech,
uh,
I think it was two years ago now at the University of Minnesota School.
I didn't really have any ties to,
and they reached out to an agent who hired me for,
and that was daunting,
right?
Because I give speeches all the time and it's usually to a room full of like
Conoco executives in Kissimmee,
Florida and I'm just there for the check.
But
the graduation speeches intense,
that's a hopefully memorable,
hopefully formative.
Hopefully you're talking to people who have incredibly open minds and it's such
a meaningful transition point in their lives,
so
everyone should go watch it.
Um,
but what I focused on was be interesting.
I think
you know,
here you're,
you're here for a week where I've gathered my favorite friends and one of the
reasons why the week is so fun for everybody is that everyone else here is
totally interesting,
right?
Not necessarily a titan of business,
but just interesting,
compassionate
adventure.
Some people who just go for it,
who are up for it.
And I think as I look around who I've hired,
who I like to work with,
who I back,
they're interesting.
They're people you want to be around,
you want to spend time with,
you want to hear their answers.
You want them to influence your thinking.
You want them to push you a little bit to try things that you haven't tried.
You want them to teach you.
And if I could give advice to someone who feels like they're looking at a maze
of opportunities and none of them is particularly presented or they're not sure
how they want to get ahead or distinguished themselves,
I think pursuing a,
a course of life that embraces interestingness.
And by the way,
I don't think people are born interesting.
I think it's actually something you can accrue living abroad,
volunteering for a group like charity,
water and going into the field,
taking an actual service job,
going in and talking to the people around you and having meaningful
conversations,
including the homeless people,
including a,
your neighbors and people who are actually working for wage.
Um,
getting involved in politics briefly.
You know,
I think I,
I campaign for Obama a couple of times and I was everything from one of his top
fundraisers to,
I actually spent time in the field in Elko,
Nevada,
which put me into the mobile home living rooms of some of the poorest people in
the country who,
who somehow were supporting,
you know,
the Republican Party in that election.
And it was,
it was surreal,
but it gave me a life perspective that I don't think I would have had otherwise.
So,
um,
I think those kinds of things make for a much more compelling people and we'll
start to present career opportunities.
So one question that I'd love to ask is when you were sort of in your most
recent sweet spot of wealth accumulation,
uh,
whether it was related to what you did with Twitter or otherwise,
were there any particular shifts,
routines,
habits,
that helped you because it would maintain that peak output or achieve what you
did?
Yeah,
so I mean,
you know my personal story,
so I certainly have been fortunate to make a bunch of money in last few years.
But Penn bubble one,
I made a bunch of money,
I levered up,
lost it all and a lot more leaving me millions of dollars in the hall,
was able to work it back out to zero by 2005 and since then,
you know a lot of work,
a few ups and downs,
but it's worked out pretty well and it's looking good for the road ahead too.
So that said,
I don't think there was any particular,
like I don't think I have a calendaring function or an email function or
anything like that.
That's like a hack as much as I would point to two things that I think shifted
the nature of my business.
One was that before I had really made any money at all,
and before I had any business doing this,
my then girlfriend,
who's now my wife crystal and I moved out of silicon valley up to Truckee.
I mean literally took ourselves out of the game as a,
you know,
an angel and venture investor.
Like how do you,
how do you manage a venture practice from up in Lake Tahoe?
And yet what I realized was that being in the city,
I was just playing defense the whole time I was taking these coffee meetings,
listening to these poor pitches,
you know,
being,
being friendly and kind of obliging people with their ideas.
But,
uh,
I'd spend all day in these meetings and I'd get home and I'd be like,
shit,
I,
I haven't actually accomplished anything.
I would go to the cocktail and dinner parties I was invited to,
but they weren't actually the people I wanted to spend the time with.
And so I was just,
I was just reacting to everything rather than actually going out and
playing offense.
And so Chris and I moved up to Tahoe and we quite literally built a list of
people we want it to know better and we just started inviting them to come up
and stay with us in Tahoe.
Um,
you were definitely one of those people,
right?
And you came up and spent a lot of time with us there.
We,
I also started running list of the companies that I wanted to get to know better
and I just went in deep with them and ask them to come up to Tahoe.
And so I was playing offense now and I had a perfect excuse for why I couldn't
get coffee with all the randoms and like,
Hey,
I'm sorry,
I'm just not in San Francisco.
I'm three hours away.
There were a couple of successive sue drew who drove all the way up there.
Uh,
but for the most part I was able to pick and choose the interactions that I
thought were going to be most valuable to me,
to my wife,
into my business.
And that was a huge shift and it was risky as hell.
Cause I,
I mean,
I couldn't even really afford the house we bought up there when we first bought
it.
$600,000 three bedroom house.
Uh,
and,
and I certainly didn't have a strong enough brand that I could afford to just
walk away from the game.
But I made a conscious decision to play offense from up there and that worked
out.
I mean,
I got to know guys like you really well.
Travis spent a lot of time in our house.
I haven't Liam's and Jason Goldman from the Twitter team.
Uh,
we had teams like,
uh,
I mean the local guys,
there's a great deal.
We sold to go daddy.
We just had many,
many teams as well as many friends.
Ted Rheingold who found our doctrine cats are now COO at one of our hottest
companies in venture was a guy we got to know very well from staying in our
house.
TV,
you'll have itch CEO and founder of open DNS guy.
We got to know really well stay in our place in Truckee.
And so these are people who would just go deep with Garrett camp.
Spent some time there.
Just just a really,
really cool crew that I think we got to know way better and build much more
meaningful relationships,
breaking bread,
making dinner,
uh,
hiking,
skiing,
that kind of stuff.
The second thing that I think was different was that after a couple of years of
trying to explain to people why Twitter was going to be a real business,
you know,
people look at me like,
how are they ever going to make any money?
And I'm like,
man,
if you don't see that,
and so I finally just said,
fuck it.
I'm not here to convince you anymore.
I'm just going to buy all your stock.
And there was just this,
there was a bit that flipped for me as a seed investor,
you have to be very collaborative.
You're constantly trying to get,
you know,
basically bring people into your world view and say,
okay,
do you see the future of this company?
This is why you want to invest in this company and the series a or series B.
This is why you want to buy this,
why you want to work there.
And I got so fed
up with doing that on Twitter,
I was just like,
fuck it.
If you,
if you can't see it anymore,
then you don't deserve to make any money on this company.
There's just like just on hand the fucking shares,
I'll take them.
And so I just started buying that stock up from early investors who wanted to
bail,
et cetera.
And by the time of the IPO,
my affiliated funds that were doing this own more of it than anybody else,
we had about 18% of the company.
And so that worked.
Uh,
and so there's this,
there's a few times where,
you know,
that wasn't necessarily the polite or most political way to go about this thing.
Uh,
it certainly,
it was daunting the amount of money I had to raise to buy that much of the
company.
But the bitch has flipped man.
I was like,
fuck it.
I'm just not going to play this traditionally anymore.
No.
The uh,
just to touch on one aspect of that,
I know we have to get ready for dinner and run in a few minutes.
We'll wrap up and maybe do around too.
Sometimes people like this.
Otherwise it's seventies disco night tonight.
Are you ready?
Oh,
you have no idea how hard I sacrificed luggage space for all of my other stuff
so I could get my disco gear here.
So can I just ask the luggage space question?
Yes.
Is is that why you insist on wearing the speedo when you swim here?
Is that,
please tell me.
There's some reason to,
other than at lunch we,
we came to the conclusion that you might actually be aspiring to be a seven year
old German man at some point.
Like that's the,
that's the path your life is on.
Like Bruce Jenner is on a transition to womanhood and you're on a path to
transition to being a seven year old German man.
I was thinking more like a Greek men cause I saw this photo,
it would actually wouldn't know it wasn't a photo.
There was this guy walking down the beach passing me and a friend and I was in
these like really baggy board shorts,
like cool fucking Brazilian surfer style.
Horrible.
The swimming,
by the way.
It's like swimming with a parachute behind you,
uh,
by walking down in this,
this Greek guy won it,
wanders by,
he's got like he's Ballou skivvies on that are just like his guts hanging out.
Oh.
Like basically covering up 70% of them covered with obviously like silver back
hair,
massive gold chains glasses could not look fucking happier and he just gave zero
fucks about Arpin and whatsoever.
So I was like,
you know,
I need to like put it on the training bra if I'm going to get to that point.
So I do wear the,
uh,
the speed of them.
No,
but your power move today was you came to the lunch table on the beach with
regular trunks on and everyone commented like,
oh,
thank God Tim,
wear regular trunks.
And then as you walk towards the beach,
you dropped your regular trucks.
They were almost where they tearaways and revealed the speedo and then it
proceeded to swim.
Well,
the excuse that I'll use is a part of the reason I think I failed to learn to
swim properly for a long time.
It was partially a wardrobe malfunction cause I'd wear these baggy shorts,
it would hold me back.
So,
um,
this is a,
this is my effort to be more dolphin.
Like unless drowning monkey like,
all right,
well it does,
it does work in the water.
It's just on land,
on land.
It's a bit,
it can be offensive to,
uh,
to,
to the,
to the more sensitive Americans among us.
But uh,
yes.
So that also takes up less space.
It's,
it's,
you can fold it up,
but it was,
I figured I really wanted to believe that you weren't wearing those because
you've liked them as much as it were.
What are the structures here?
What are the guys doing?
Kite surfing or something.
He was like,
is he wearing those seriously?
Or like,
ironically he did that.
So on a completely unrelated note,
uh,
we're the fuck was I going to go with that?
Who knows?
I tell you what,
I know we're tight for time,
so I will,
um,
two last questions and then maybe we can revisit a bunch of this another time.
But is there any purchase that you have made?
Could be years ago or recently,
less than a hundred dollars it had a a significant positive impact on your life.
Okay.
The F,
I mean just draft top of the head.
The first thing that jumped in my head was there's a Buckminster fuller book
called,
I seem to be a verb,
incredibly,
incredibly limited production.
You have to buy advantage if you're going to find it.
I regret even saying it out loud now because there are so few copies out there.
They'll be hoovered up by your audience.
They're gone.
But that book and it's special.
It's actually,
it's beautiful inside.
It's not like his other books,
which are just long,
long texts.
It's graphic lettering and photographs and you read it through on the top half
first and then you flip the book upside down and you read it through on the
bottom half and the other direction it's super compelling are some great
thoughts in there and it'll cost you,
I mean,
I don't know what your mark,
what your viewers are going to do to the market,
but it's under a hundred bucks,
but it's incredibly special.
Very,
very treasured.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Those,
those will disappear pretty quickly.
So get them while they're hot,
I guess.
Uh,
any last pieces of advice or recommendations to leave with the would be
entrepreneurs who are listening to this,
people who were thinking about starting a company of some type.
I think that that's their path.
Maybe they're just a shitty employee like I was a and m are out there hoping to
have a headstart in somewhere in advantage with what,
uh,
what advice or recommendations would you make?
My first recommendation is be honest with yourself.
Most people aren't that person.
And I think we are an environment right now where there's so much venture
capital and the industry,
you know,
the tech industry has been shown to be so cool,
great perks and a great fast pass to path the wealth that it's very attractive
right now to posers.
And I think most people aren't cut out to be founders.
Most people aren't.
The entrepreneurs will have that ultimate success and it's polluted our
industry.
You know,
we have way too many shitty companies that are pulling all the great talent away
from inevitably great companies.
We have way too many people wasting time on competitive ventures that have no
hope whatsoever.
And so I think you have to be really,
really honest.
Are you a founder or are you an employee?
And one of those things that we touched on earlier is that inevitability of
success,
if you are,
people ask me what went through my head when I lost,
uh,
$12 million in the matter of a week.
And that was another $4 million on top of that,
just a really highly levered public market by which went upside down in a crash.
Uh,
and then $4 million more from their leaving me deep,
deep in the hole.
And people ask like,
were you sad?
Were you,
and I just,
my brain works in a way where I wasn't sad,
I was pissed.
It was a bummer,
but I just knew I would always make that money back and get back into a good
spot again.
It was just going to take longer.
I just knew that I would never be the guy who just lived out and declared
bankruptcy and living in the hold up the whole time.
I just knew I would make back the millions of dollars and then go from there.
Uh,
when I went out and branched off and started my own firm,
I spent money to do the documents that are big,
big firm would do right off the bat.
And even though my other,
it's like we don't really need to do this.
It's small firms notes,
well this is going to be a huge thing.
So I want to do that now.
When I set out to raise $1 billion in the fall of,
of 2010,
that was absurd.
I didn't even have office space.
I had one other employee at the time who managed our,
our back office from a winery and Healdsburg.
Um,
and so I had no business raising that money.
I work cowboy shirts the whole time and uh,
rarely left Truckee California to do at,
asked everyone to fly their fancy jets into trucking and get it done at the
greasy spoon.
And so there's just a,
I just knew there was an inevitability at this thing was going to work out and
then I wouldn't fail at it.
If you're not the kind of person to think that way.
If you really don't have that gene where you know what it's going to work out.
No,
you don't hope,
you know,
then you shouldn't be a founder.
So I hope that doesn't depress anybody,
but hopefully I'm saving a bunch of pain.
There are also many paths to amassing incredible fortunes.
Being a founder is actually a pretty thin slice of that pie and a very high risk
sort of binary way to approach things.
What is the,
what is the movie that you can quote from most readily?
The Big Lebowski?
I mean,
you,
you start with the opening scene with Sam and I can read,
I can recite the whole thing.
I go to Lebowski fest every year.
I,
uh,
my,
my division at,
at a Google was secret and we working on secret stuff that now you're starting
to see kind of all the spectrum and wireless system stuff they did.
We actually launched the first weather balloons,
you know,
Cassie went on to build loon and stuff like that.
We'd dug the fiber,
et cetera.
But that whole division was called project Lebowski.
And if you,
anytime we launched something or achieving a milestone,
everyone got achiever shirts.
It's a,
you know,
a little blocky urban achievers,
inner city children of promise without the necessary means.
Fourth necessarily means for higher education.
Uh,
so Phillip Seymour Hoffman recipes.
So yeah,
that was a,
that's a pretty important movie for me.
Awesome.
Where can people find you on the Internet?
I'll give one more book recommendations since the,
the Bucky book is probably an advantage.
The magic of thinking big,
I think,
uh,
is,
is one that I found very helpful.
Other people might as well,
but on the,
on the net
book recommendations right now.
Sure.
You know,
one of my favorite,
favorite books,
what's,
uh,
is,
the essential scratch and sniff guide to becoming a wine expert is a fantastic
author by my fabulous wife.
It literally,
you know,
the master smile,
a Richard Bets.
Uh,
there's incredible knowledge in that book.
So my wife and Wendy McNaughton nail straight are combined to make a a
children's book for adults.
It'll will teach you how to drink wine.
That's indispensable for any aspiring honors.
The North,
Super Fun.
I might have to have bets on at some point to talk about hacking the master
Somme test.
He's,
that's exactly what he does.
He teaches people how to take that test long lunch and talked about it.
He's a fascinating dude.
So the the web,
the ever expanding web of Soka.
So where am I?
I'm at Sacca on Twitter.
I just don't use the Instagram's very much anymore.
I'm also add sack on periscope and that I've been using a lot.
I think periscope changes everything.
Cool,
man.
Speaking about changing everything,
I think it's a disco nights we've got to get running.
That's right.
All right.
Thanks brother.
Always fun.
Thanks Sam.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming and a lot of it took place with designers from around the
world.
And here's how it works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world,
we'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward.
And many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing it in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's [inaudible] 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you by a new sponsor,
so listen up folks.
This is a good one because have you ever want it to be as powerful as a bullet
wearing Ninja from an 1980s movie or as flamboyant as big gay Al Big Al in south
park or as sleek as a black panther in the Amazon on the hunt wealth,
there's great man's,
because I've been testing this product that you wrap around your genitals and it
makes you feel like a superhero and it is called beyond.
I've spent the last two to three weeks traveling with underwear from these guys
and they are comfy.
I got to tell you,
it feels like a Geisha has giving your groin a hug and it's not just for dudes,
but if you go to meet [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
that's m e e u n D I e s.com forward slash Tim,
you can see all of the underwear that I've been wearing.
There's some pretty ridiculous ones and I will also highlight my favorite.
You'll probably be able to guess which it is.
These underwear made from micro Medallia,
which is extruded from Austria and beechwood trees in the Alps.
Yes,
fancy.
And it's two times softer than cotton,
scientifically tested using the collar bottom method developed in Kyoto.
You know,
those Japanese very crafty.
And uh,
I will say a few things.
Number one,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
you get to see all of these spectacular underwear that I've been wearing and I
am a bit of an underwear connoisseur,
socks,
fashion sense with sweatpants,
not so much underwear.
I understand.
So check them out.
And if you go to [inaudible] dot com forward slash [inaudible] you will also be
able to see lots of hot ladies wearing at me undies,
female underwear.
And that's just a lot of goodness for both the men and the women out there.
So check it out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
I love these underwear and a,
I'm going to be packing tonight probably six to 12 pair to take with me to
Australia.
They're great.
Check em out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash.
Tim.
And until next time,
thank you for listening.
Okay.
Yeah.